it's Fan Appreciation Month that screen
junkies and her reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that
you voted for here's the honest trailer
you voted number one for some reason
[Music]
from the studio that brought you the
dream workspace comes the animated
feature that revolutionized kids movies
patter out than in I always say by
adding 90 minutes of non-stop in jokes
Shrek meets reg and over who used to
sound just like Chris Farley but when
Chris passed away he transformed into an
ogre who sounds just like that one voice
Mike Myers does oka don't care when his
gas-based way of life is threatened
he'll set off on a quest with donkey a
character is sadly more famous than
Eddie Murphy these days
Fiona a princess struggling with by ogre
disorder and an entire kingdoms worth of
fairy tale characters that Disney had
yet to snatch up together they'll prove
that nothing can overcome the power of
true love or more specifically the power
of having a dragon murderer enemies wow
they really just straight-up killed him
at the end wait so who's running the
government now you just started a coup
why are you dancing in a swamp enjoy
early computer animation that looks just
as good as modern computer animation
that hasn't finished rendering for a
story that parodies all the overused
Disney tropes full of overused Disney
troves like The Reluctant ugly hero who
thinks no one can love them the
no-nonsense princess the creepy horny
government official who wants to be king
and the lovable animal sidekick hey if
you can't beat them join them
while at the same time mercilessly
mocking them settle in for a story with
an important lesson only ugly people can
be together wait that can't be right
true love will turn you into a monster
no that's not it either
stinky
your own condo no sure people deserve
ridicule men of farquaad's stature are
in short supply oh hey look these guys
are doing the Macarena ha references so
come along for the blockbuster hit that
appeal to adults and kids alike and won
the first Academy Award for Best
Animated Film all by making fun of
Disney's obsession with franchising and
merchandising that spawned one great
sequel to bad sequels a spinoff a
Broadway musical a ton of unfortunate
green merchandise and that Smash Mouth
song that's been stuck in your head
since 2001
[Music]
Tyler couldn't get away from your heart
smashmouth mated to the by children and
those boots and it is number four on
that billboard
well the play star club and they don't
stop coming duck can you have relaxed
[Music]
go check for blender the singer is guys
yeah
[Music]
starring Chris Bartley Beverly Hills
claw by Shrek tool mini-me
mother of donkeys and creepy animation
errors I'm a delivery boy Swamp Thing
what's up with all the Shrek memes I've
been seeing let's see what this is all
about it's Shrek I'm so happy
shrek is love shrek oh no no no no shrek
is not love shrek is not life Oh
who likes his drag be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers thanks to fans
more es Connor I and Renee G for helping
to vote shrek the number one fan choice
on his trailer and thanks to epic Lloyd
of epic rap battles for his epic Smash
Mouth vocals and thanks to all of you
who helped make Fan Appreciation Month
great to check out all of our fans voted
honest trailers including our epic
collaboration with Michael Bolton on
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
click the Box on the left and if you
can't get enough kids movies
click the box in the right to see which
ones are actually worth watching hey now
you're all stars this is my swamp not
the buttons not the gumdrop buttons
according to all known laws of aviation
wait wrong movie oh Gers are like onions
it's all over now
shrek is love shrek is life